fans may not be the most exciting things
on the road admits our car reviewer
Montes but reviewing this new ma NT GE
right here could be rather interesting
why someone has loaded 15 sacks of
playground sand inside and now Montes is
supposed to do a test drive he hopes he
can jettison it at some point
locked and loaded the ma n t GE handles
those 400 kilos easy as pie with its 2
litre diesel engine it comes in four
output levels ranging between 75 and 130
kilowatts we checked out the second most
powerful unit with 103 kilowatts
officially fuel consumption is rated at
seven point four liters for 100
kilometers this reckons the van could
have used longer gear ratios especially
for the higher gears doing 120
kilometers per hour on the Autobahn you
really hear the engine plugging away in
the mid revs range with longer gear
ratios it would be less intrusive for
table the t GE comes with front rear and
all-wheel drive but the 4x4 version is
only available in combination with the
two biggest engines
on bumpy roads like this one says
monthís you appreciate the suspension
see it costs extra but it's entertaining
whatever you need your van for the T GE
has versions for every purpose panel van
single cabin crew cab or combi van you
can have a regular high or extra high
roof and the van comes in a range of
lengths the permutations are endless
we're testing the long version of the
panel van with a high roof it's just
over six meters 80 long and nearly two
meters 60 tall placing it in the medium
sized range
the cargo section has a 14 cubic metre
capacity and a payload of over 1.3
tonnes and if that's not enough the
trailer hitch can pull another 3 tonnes
as to be expected from a van the
interior is a no-frills affair but not a
loveless one the materials are more than
decent as is the workmanship
and similar style to a car there are
buttons on the steering wheel to operate
the radio and sat-nav
a pleasant touch and a practical one for
delivering cargo is the array of stowage
compartments the ma MTG is big on space
and big on safety
it comes with adaptive cruise control an
emergency brake assist automatic high
beams and an active Lane assist the
entry price in Germany is 32 thousand
euros meanwhile Montes has finally found
somewhere to dump the sand buddy can't
believe it he's at a playground but
there's no sandbox he's evidently stuck
with that load in the back
then again the tge has so much space
that he has no problem leaving the sacks
on board for the time being
you